[Laughter]
so tell me the story of what happened
and how you came to hug Prince Harry
so we were sailing and we had just
finished our competition where we came
in fourth and on our way back to the
harbour we we heard a voice from behind
us asking for Ryan mm-hmm well Ryan's
our skipper where's Ryan where's Ryan
where's Ryan he just kept saying it over
and over like he's but we finally looked
over and realized it was Prince Harry
we're like oh okay so you realise it's
print area what do you say I go hey can
I get a hug later and he's like sure how
about right now
so we're on two different boats sir he's
like we come together and you hop into
my hop it was go into his boat hop onto
his boat and just big old squeeze and
picked him up no no you didn't just pick
him up you lifted Harry off his feet
like Harry was like whoa he liked it
okay do you see the smile I saw this but
then what happened when you went to hug
Megan uh he he definitely was a little
scared you could see it seen his eyes
but he was like be careful I knew she
was pregnant super excited for him I'm
very excited for the two of them and
Royal baby again but yeah I gave her a
very delicate light hug and did you what
else did you do before you hugged her
what hat what happened before you hugged
her
I was actually after okay okay so it's
like what happened after I hugged her he
goes oh be careful and I go no no
congratulations and you touch the Royal
baby bump pretty sure I touched the
Royal baby bump yes your vibe boy or
girl girl girl girl what did that moment
mean to you now that has gone crazy
viral so
it's truly an honor to just meet them
but also it's it's as equal an honor for
me to be here representing the u.s. at
the Invictus games and more so in if
anything I just wanted to thank him and
show him my gratitude for what he has
done for the wounded injured and ill
community for the militaries across the
world it is special what he's done and
you see the hugs the happiness from all
the veterans and it's interesting
because you have people here that could
have fought against each other a war yes
potentially we don't ask those questions
no but the spirit of the games are we're
here to heal through competition also
you loved a hug I ain't the deal of why
you love the hustle so I'm I'm a retired
member of the Air Force and through our
program studies have been done that say
12 hugs a day giving and or receiving
will promote growth and and release
positive energy so whenever we're with
the group with a fw2 group we hug and as
a big guy mm-hmm I give great hugs can I
get a hug let's get a hug here Oh God
that was a hug that was a hose ugh but
know that one invigorates your whole
soul